يباشر الاف الاطباء الشباب في بريطانيا
اضرابا مدته اربعه ايام للمطالبه باجور
افضل في خضم ازمه غلاء معيشه ما يزيد طبعا
من الضغوط على النظام الصحي في البلاد
اضرابهم قد يشمل القطاع الصحي بشكل كامل
ووفقا للاتحاد للاتحاد الخدمات الصحيه
الوطنيه هناك نحو 350 الف موعد طبي قد
يؤجل بما في ذلك طبعا العمليات الطبيه
وسبق للاطباء مشاهدينا طبعا الاطباء
الشباب ان اضربوا مده ثلاثه ايام الشهر
الماضي ما اثر على 175 الف موعد فيما حذر
هنا الرئيس التنفيذي لاتحاد هيئه الخدمات
الصحيه الوطنيه من التاثير المحتمل
للاضراب ووصفه بالمفجع ودعا كلا الجانبين
الى انهاء هذه المعركه صحيفه غاردين
البريطانيه وصفت الاضراب الاخير بالاخطا
حيث يعد هذا اطول اضراب في الخدمه الصحيه
منذ ان اتخذ الممرضين والتواقم الطبيه
والاسعاف وغير هؤلاء من العاملين الصحيين
اجراءات مماثله العام الماضي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات